[Music]
this is bear son it was the home of your
grandparents and their grandparents
before then but out there beyond the
edge of the world
why is the home of the Dragons
and I believe this your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you don't know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah
okay
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up
he's not the only one
[Music]
another night three weeks is more like a
bright light theory
yeah yours is better probably there is
an armada with enough cages for all of
our dragon vein
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden world I wouldn't destroy
everything you realize
even nothing without you a blender if
primo succeeds there won't be any
dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it so what are you gonna do about
it
suit up gang we have one shot you
brought a baby to a battle
the hidden morals have really touched
the key
right but inside
Kunis not a word okay chip
it's kit yeah I need you to feel it it's
cold it's great you're covering pelts oh
and you're auditioning with some big
Hollywood star oh really
who and action hold brother's the Beast
can smell your fear dragon show yourself
sorry I didn't see that in the script
this push to them not me okay hey it's
your bit all you need to do is leap on
this mark when I say no no no no get
back we'll just explaining the Q the Q
is ah oh okay
be honest toothless do I come across as
too broody hmm
because Arthur tongue I'm just trying to
remember where I left my keys brothers
no all of us will see daybreak
but dragon show yourself
toothless no no put it down it's lunch
everybody
catering stop not maybe I got your
salmon I'm a little confused about my
part really you first I'm dead then I'm
not no one knows you my mother is
brothers we have four strong we have
fought hard and we must continue to
fight until our foes are defeated
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
toothless would you mind if I am can we
get him cleaned up please DreamWorks How
to Train Your Dragon the hidden world is
almost here and we're gonna get you
caught up in no time it all started with
Berk
home of Vikings sheep and Dragons this
is hiccup and our story really begins
when he catches the most powerful dragon
of all toothless and pretty soon they're
best friends and convincing hiccup staff
and everyone else that dragons and
Vikings don't have to be enemies thank
you then all the pickup's friends become
true dragon riders like Fishlegs it's
not loud ruffnut and tuffnut and Astrid
who becomes kind of a thing with hiccup
whoa and just when we thought we knew
everything about training dragons
hiccups mom shows up and changes
everything again and Drago and his alpha
appear
and kind of ruin everything but luckily
Julis and hiccup find a way to save the
day
and that brings us up to right now it's
hidden dragon worth witness the epic
conclusion of the friendship of a
lifetime a right button it's time
[Music]
Sarge we got situation someone took the
ball the ball how cute toothless that is
not yours
hand it over all right I'm getting too
old for this shift there were dragons
when I was a boy where they went only a
few know our story changed the world
forever we did it the world's first
dragon Viking utopia utopia maybe Mike
slay splendid and more Oh
sanitary hey bud wait up
oh my god he's not the only one she's a
light fury you oh sorry
did she just disappear Wow
and it's a hidden dragon worst
toothless go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours and him over I will never
give him up then I will destroy
everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing without your dragon
show them what you got buddy
[Music]
if you and me bud always
[Music]
[Music]